continúa la atención entre Armenia y
azerbaiyán con los ataques a gran escala
de las tropas a series hacia la línea de
contacto al este de Armenia por la
mañana el portavoz del Ministerio de
defensa de Armenia manifestó que estos
ataques continúan en diferentes zonas
como Shot y bartenis al noreste de
Armenia y goris al sur también
estuvieron operando drones de ataque en
el pueblo de yermook al este del
territorio hay una gran cantidad de
infraestructura civil dañada como
consecuencia de la artillería Como por
ejemplo casas centros de administración
de los pueblos vehículos de civiles e
incluso Campos cultivados por otro lado
en este momento se están desalojando
varios pueblos mientras crece el número
de soldados muertos y civiles heridos ya
son varios los países que han marcado su
preocupación y han invitado a las partes
a Cesar el fuego como por ejemplo
Francia Rusia Luxemburgo y muchos de
ellos como por ejemplo Estados Unidos
manifestó que tiene evidencias de los
ataques de azerbaiyán e instó a Rusia
para que use su influencia en la región
para lograr una estabilización sin
embargo la situación continúa tensa en
la frontera casi sin cambios en cuanto
al logro de una estabilidad